new in theaters this weekend peppermint
and the nun what will you see this is
your weekend ticket
[Music]
you know what I miss Jennifer Garner
from alias and daredevil I mean don't
get me wrong 13 going on 30 Jennifer
Garner is good but she was meant for
action yes peppermint comes out this
weekend and guess what kick-ass Jennifer
Garner is back in this movie she plays
the mother of a gang murdered family who
let seek revenge on the game members
corrupt judges and dirty cops who did
her bar maybe even see what you think
you saw this movie is directed by Pierre
Morel the director of taken the ultimate
parent seeking revenge movie so we can
definitely expect to see some sweet
sweet parental retribution this movie is
for you if you like parental action
movies like taken weapon wielding
Jennifer Garner is your favorite
Jennifer Garner or if you're a fan of
Justice who is ready to their pants this
weekend looking for a totally not scary
movie this weekend that I totally am not
scared to see it all then you should
like me totally be okay with going to
see the nun Oh God
[Music]
chronologically the first in the
conjuring franchise the story follows a
troubled priest and a Catholic novitiate
as they investigate the death of a nun
in a cloistered Abbey in Romania oh
right and there's a demonic nun this
movies for you if you liked any of the
other conjuring or Annabelle movies
scary movies in general are you saying
or if Sister Act just wasn't scary
enough for you
it was that is your weekend ticket what
will you see and do me a simple favor
and check back next week for a simple
favor
[Music]
[Music]